at Apple we don't think you should have  to choose between an iPhone and quality  healthcare because you can have both  with apps like Apple health you can  monitor your fitness and create your own  medical ID but that's not all the iPhone  can assist with I hear and throat exams  and function as a thermometer with a  five-day internal forecast plus our  entire suite of Apple products can  provide all of your health care needs  from routine physical examinations and  health maintenance to advanced  diagnostics hey Siri is this tumor  malignant here are some images of tumors  I found on the web  Apple can also assist in surgery pain  management and recovery emergency blood  transfusion new preventative procedures  like mammograms and routine Colorado  well you guys thanks to my mom  the only health care you'll need and  soon  you